very subtle chair of a really big
announcement to make for you guys today
to you guys before you guys it doesn't
matter it's going to change your lives
very minor Lee which is very exciting
ever had cold yeah feel bad for me I did
one of my favorite things that I hate
that people do the most online I use
social media to let everyone know my
health status and you all felt for it
felt for it mmm-hmm back to the big
announcement it's really big for me did
a light just turned around what did a
not so beloved world leader and my
approach this video have a common they
were Stalin is that even correct I don't
know anything about history or the world
I just regurgitate sort of things I've
kind of heard before big announcement
today go to one choice of the trip
choice can't talk stop living in the
delusional world big announcement okay
I'm just gonna say it this is a big
announcement it has to do with a project
I've been working on all year long and
finally get to invalid for you guys and
they'll it for you guys and then Valen
Valen valid for you guys yep
that's the sentence well no I'm thinking
about that's too much and it's not gonna
be that excited I have a podcast not as
exciting as I thought it might have
sounded on the fact that everyone else
in the world has the podcast but here's
the really exciting thing about my
podcast is it's different that's what
everyone is something that's not really
different tries to say about the thing
that they really wanted to be different
but it is I happen here's how my podcast
works it is both an audio and visual
podcast oh my god the pockets is called
not your deep with grace Helbig because
I don't like emotions I am by a YouTube
friend of mine over two of my podcast
set I have a set sort of I asked some
questions that are not too deep we film
an interview for like an hour long and
then we would do a YouTube challenge but
it's not just any YouTube challenge
it's a stupid YouTube challenge which
makes it seem like that is any YouTube
challenge I take a challenge that
already exists on YouTube and I try and
make it dumber and then we do that
starting September 1st every Monday on
its grace you will get the video portion
of not to deeps right here on its grace
and at the same time you can go over to
SoundCloud or iTunes and listen to the
full audio interview if you so choose
you should choose that you should choose
that choose that choose that choose that
there are links that sounds on iTunes
down below so that you can go over and
subscribe to the podcast cuz I learned
that's something you can do with the
podcast don't you wait your taste buds
to salivate your whistle here is the
trailer for not too deep with grace
Helbig enjoy grace Helbig I love crafts
to this day you know I airbrush this did
you
of course I didn't don't said I'm gonna
pop them because you feel it in your
bottom hole you weigh yourself you do
where the pitch if you saw someone
bleeding out of their ears on the tube
would you tell them they've got a cover
they know what's going on I trusted the
fire that's on my tombstone the youtuber
yes
what's up I'm sweating I don't know